[Music]
[Applause]
they turned up in their thousands
excited to see a rare solar eclipse
for one minute part of Australia's
Northwestern Coast was plunged Into
Darkness at midday on Thursday
[Applause]
people and tourists from around the
world camp for days across the country
to see the event brilliant for many it
was worth the wait oh just so thrilled
and felt so eerie and I've had shakes I
just like so surprised and just
something like I'd never experienced
before it was probably yeah the most
exciting minute that we've had for a
long time I think the so-called hybrid
eclipses only occur a few times a
century its shadow tracked from the
Indian Ocean to the Pacific and fell
mostly over water
the lucky few people in its path either
saw darkness of a turtle eclipse or
what's known as a ring of fire around
the new moon as the sun Shone from
behind
it could also be observed from remote
parts of Indonesia and East to Mall
those who missed it will have a long
wait for another chance
the next one isn't due until 2031.
Al Jazeera